welcome back guys uh as you know here on
the channel we've been doing a lot of
plot leaks lately and this is for doctor
strange and multiverse of bandits so
what i did is i took all the trailers
and clips and i organized them for you
and i compared them to the leaks that
we've seen so far
stick around the the audio obviously is
going to be a little different just
because i cut it up and not necessarily
um
obviously as the trailer intended them
to but bear with me it definitely does
put the whole movie in perspective let's
get started
the nightmare begins
we'll walk through it
become a hero
prove it it's too dangerous
why we tampered with the stability of
space time
wonder
i knew somewhere later you'd show up
i made mistakes
and people were hurt i'm not here to
talk about westview
then what are you here for
i need your help
guess what
what do you know about the multiverse
this had his theories
but i become the enemy
it doesn't seem fair
he believed it was dangerous
he was right
hope you understand
who or what
you break the rules
[Music]
i'm sorry steve
[Music]
we should tell him the truth
greatest
[Music]
threat what do you know about the
multiverse
twin universes
and we don't know
your desecration of reality
i dream the same dream
is you
things just got out of hand
meant for
any if this
did what i had to do
this path exacts a heavy toll
and obviously we wouldn't see anything
from the finale in the trailers so there
is at least probably 30 minutes left in
the movie from the point at which uh
defender strange dead body comes back to
life uh so let me know in the comments
what you guys think i i worked hard on
this when this one was at least a couple
days
worth uh i had to put together all the
pieces from all the trailers and clips
and i organize them for you i would
really appreciate a subscription if you
don't mind i am doing this every day so
i'll see you guys tomorrow thank you so
much have a good one